dix-huit mois charlie est foudroyé par
la bactérie mangeuse de chair pour
freiner sa progression
on l'en petit des deux jambes au milieu
du tibia mais la bactérie a eu le temps
d'infecter les cellules responsables de
la croissance des os
la conséquence à mesure que charlie
grandissait tibia dévie vers l'intérieur
aujourd'hui à 16 ans l'angle de ses
tibias et si prononcée que l'adolescent
peine à marcher
l'acce mécanique est déviée d'environ 30
à 40 degrés par rapport à la casse
mécanique normal donc c'était une des
formations assez importante parmi les
plus sévères que j'ai déjà rencontré
on envisage l'amputation complète des
tibias
mais la rencontre entre le docteur de la
base ball icade une entreprise de québec
changera le cours de l'histoire
un autre scénario de 20 mm spécialisée
en solutions orthopédique beau décade a
développé un logiciel unique capable de
corriger les cas complexes
on commencera par la jambe gauche
redresser l'os de charlie nécessitera un
seul trait de scie impossible d'en faire
plus on vit actuellement environ 1 30 %
d'amélioration
ce qui est quand même significatif étant
donné que l'objectif ultime c'est quand
même d'appareiller de manière viable ce
jeune homme là est d'améliorer sa
qualité de vie et sa capacité de
déplacement ou couper le logiciel de
body cas de tests toutes les
possibilités
la meilleure d'entre elles est imprimé
en 3d c'est le guide de coupe on fixe le
guide de coupe sur l'os on insère la
lame dans le guide on si l'os on sait
par le guide de coupe on redresse las
on insère un greffon dans l'encoche on
fixe une plaque
la correction est stable complété le
redressement se déroule comme prévu
depuis l'opération de la jambe gauche
la démarche de charlie s'est grandement
améliorée good job man forts de leur
succès godet cas de charlie et son
médecin procéderont à la correction de
la jambe droite ce mardi ici d'annie
lemieux radio canada montréal